thierry mariani merci entre en direct
avec nous sur rt france où est député
européen vous êtes rendu plusieurs fois
en crimée notamment en 2016 lors d'un
voyage parlementaire alors voie
automobile inauguré en mai 2018 par
vladimir poutine partie ferroviaire du
pont de crimes et qui a été mise en
service en décembre 2019
aujourd'hui c'est la puissance navale
qui est au coeur de la visite
monsieur mariani
pardon oui oui oui aujourd'hui c'est
effectivement la puissance navale il
faut jamais oublier que le dernier
dimanche de juillet enfin dans cette
période c'est traditionnellement ce
qu'on appelle en aussi la journée de la
flotte et que normalement c'est la
période où à sébastopol c'est le siège
de la flotte de la mer noire se déroule
une importante parade qui est l'occasion
de passer en revue la flotte navale
russe dans cette région alors on va
peut-être faire écho au sujet qu'on
vient de diffuser alors on vient de le
voir dans l'axé mais est rattachée à la
russie depuis 2014 ce référendum de la
population à un plébiscite
on continue pourtant dans la plupart des
autres médias de parler d'annexion
pourquoi selon vous écouter vous
connaissez la polémique
il faut quand même rappeler l'origine de
cette de 7,2 cette histoire au sens avec
un h majuscule
après le vote en février 2014 d'une loi
bannissant le russe des médias et
bannissant le russe comme langue
officielle possible pour les habitants
de crime et c'est à dire en réalité pour
une partie des ukrainiens à l'époque la
population s'est soulevée et a décidé
d'organiser un référendum
quand on dit a décidé d'organiser un
référendum c'est en réalité
l'assemblée régionale de 5,0 paul ce
référendum qui a été organisée soyons
honnêtes dans des conditions de rapidité
qui ont peut-être pas permis toutes les
conditions habituelles pour un scrutin a
quand même donné une majorité trendnet
est très clair pour le rattachement de
la crimée à la russie et quand je dis
que les conditions n'étaient pas
particulièrement
dir inattaquable quoi qu'il en soit le
résultat a été très net
vous savez au parlement européen
maintenant on parle comme certains ne
savent pas comment contester le résultat
de ce référendum qui marquait quand même
une volonté manifeste du peuple de
crimée en parle maintenant du respect
des minorités mais comme je dis quand on
veut respecter les minorités ça veut
dire qu'il ya avant tout une majorité et
la majorité des habitants de crimée en
mars 2014 avait choisi le retour très
clair à la russie
d'ailleurs quand vous allez dans cette
région vous voyez qu'aujourd'hui il n'y
a strictement aucun problème quand
j'entends des collègues et qui parle de
forces d'occupation russes
c'est franchement grotesque je
continuerai mieux d'y aller c'était la
volonté des habitants de crime et je
vais pas revenir sur cet épisode des
années 50 ou khrouchtchev dans un
déplacement on va dire administratif
avait attribué entre guillemets là la
crimée à à la république socialiste
soviétique d'ukraine bref au delà des
des péripéties administratives
historique
la crimée a été toujours
traditionnellement rucher des habitants
aujourd'hui sont totalement satisfaits
de cette situation alors parallèlement à
cette visite de vladimir poutine
il y à ces exercices militaires
conjoints entre l'ukraine et les pays de
l'otan est ce que c'est un hasard du
calendrier il sait pas forcément un
hasard parce que je crois que vladimir
poutine ce certes ce prétexte de la
journée de la flotte pour montrer une
fois de plus l'importance que la russie
accorde à son flanc sud et au et à la
mer noire et en réalité vous avez vu
qu'il ya quelques jours vladimir poutine
a décidé des manoeuvres exceptionnelles
une ampleur énorme parce qu'ils n'ont
rien à avoir avec les quelques milliers
d'hommes qui sont en manoeuvre en ce
moment côté ukrainien pour montrer
justement qu'elle était prête à se
défendre
donc on est dans une région les tensions
sont extrêmes les tensions sont à la
fois avec états unis et crennes mais
aussi ne l'oublions pas la fois avec la
turquie la turquie est sur le flanc sud
et pour la russie ces manoeuvres sans
qu'elle ait elle aussi décidé
d'organiser sont aussi l'occasion de
montrer d'abord calé
est en toute circonstance et
deuxièmement la visite de poutine en
crimée montre que c'est un sujet
j'allais dire non négociable vous savez
qu'on a eu une sorte de référendum en
consultation il consultation organisée
auprès du peuple russe il ya une dizaine
de jours et dans les articles de la
modification du référendum qui était
proposée y avait justement le fait que
toute cession de territoires soient non
négociable qui voulait dire en clair que
là la crimée le message est très clair
pour les occidentaux
en 2014 ce qui s'est passé est
définitive
thierry mariani vous êtes député
européen du rassemblement national vous
êtes rendu plusieurs fois en crimée
merci d'avoir été en direct avec nous
sur rt france